zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro des oneurope sur Radio sensation
et sur TV 78 une émission spéciale
enregistrée à Berlin en Allemagne et
consacré aux questions de défense nous
vous présenterons d'abord le record à
Strasbourg dans le Bas-Rhin une force
multinationale qui est né en 1992 et qui
a pour origine une initiative
franco-allemande nous vous emmènerons
ensuite également à Évreux dans l'Eure
pour y découvrir l'unité de transport
aérien franco-allemand mais avant cela
le gouvernement allemand qui augmente
ses dépenses militaires le futur avion
de combat européen on en parle avec
Thomas wieder le correspondant en
Allemagne du journal Le Monde
[Musique]
l'Allemagne
pour dire les choses n'a pas été
fondamentalement motrices dans ce projet
mais elle n'a pas non plus elle ne l'a
pas non plus bloqué en fait il y a deux
niveaux de difficultés bon c'est un
projet extrêmement lourd c'est un projet
qui doit avoir le jour à la fin des
années 2030 et le premier enjeu c'est de
c'est de construire ce qu'on appelle un
démonstrateur qui doit sur de prototype
qui doit être mis en service en à la fin
des années 2020 2027 je crois
l'Espagne s'est agrégé au projet le
problème il est il est double il est
lié au désaccord qui existe entre les
industriels parti prenantes de ce projet
notamment entre Dassault et Airbus pour
des histoires très complexes de
propriétés intellectuelles
et l'autre l'autre problème il est celui
malgré toute la volonté politique et du
financement ce qu'on a vu sous Merkel
c'est que comme vous le savez
la tout ce qui est défense est très très
contrôlé par le Parlement en Allemagne
en fait le financement de ce projet doit
être validé alors je sais plus c'est
tous les deux ans par le Bundes stack
mais en tout cas chaque tranche doit
être validé et fait l'objet de vivre
débat parce que sous Merkel les
sociaux-démocrates donc le parti de la
Scholtz bloquait très souvent pour
mettre les fonds pour pour ce projet et
souvent il bloquait parce qu'il y avait
une élection quelque part et que par
rapport à l'électorat SPD voilà alors
depuis que Scholtz et
ateliers les choses sont un petit peu
différentes la guerre en Ukraine a tout
bouleversé l'Allemagne a annoncé qu'elle
allait débloquer un front spécial de 100
milliards d'euros pour moderniser la
Bundes verts dans son discours où il
annonçait ce fond spécial scholls a
évoqué au passage le projet de d'avion
du futur mais par exemple dans l'autre
grand discours européen qu'il a fait à
Prague en août il n'en a pas parlé et
donc depuis quelques mois il y avait
côté français quelques quelques
interrogations sur la volonté de
l'Allemagne
de continuer à participer à ce projet
avec ce avec cette espèce de paradoxe
que au moment où l'Allemagne aligne 100
milliards pour sa défense
quid de de ce projet voilà l'Allemagne
semble plus pressé d'acheter des avions
américains pour porter les charges
nucléaires etc
alors les choses se sont un peu
rabibochers
cet automne il y a eu un nouveau
protocole qui a été qui a été signé
là il y a quelques jours il y a eu des
visites des ministres avec des à chaque
fois des déclarations mais oui bien sûr
on
abandonne pas le projet
moi mon intime conviction c'est que ce
projet est trop symbolique et déjà trop
engagé pour que on y renonce
il a une telle importance que il
renonçait là on pourrait reparler sans
doute de rupture des relations
franco-allemandes
en revanche c'est toujours pareil c'est
à dire que ça avance ça traîne ça avance
on craint que ça n'avance pas assez dans
les dernières dans les dernières
estimations
tout le monde table sur un retard voilà
déjà le calendrier est très lointain
mais au moins le prototype aurait deux
ou trois ans de retard sans doute donc
c'est sans doute à ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut s'attendre mais mais à la limite
le caractère très progressif de ce
projet c'est à dire qu'on avance étape
par étape permet à chaque fois malgré
tout de mesurer un peu quel est le degré
de volontarisme politique à la fois à
Paris et à Berlin
[Musique]
alors scholls le chancelier chaude ça a
dit plusieurs fois que
l'objectif était que l'Allemagne est la
plus grande armée conventionnelle
d'Europe donc à terme ça changera quand
même quelque chose
la question c'est de savoir quand et à
quel rythme parce que quand les 100
milliards d'euros ont été annoncés tout
le monde a dit assez formidable voilà
l'Allemagne non seulement va pouvoir
avoir une armée digne de ce nom des
hélicoptères qui volent des bateaux qui
qui flottent et des uniformes qui ne
t'ont pas en lambe parce que c'est
vraiment ça l'armée allemande
aujourd'hui il faut le savoir
mais
ce qui les experts des questions de
financement de l'armée disent deux
choses 1 que
c'est 100 milliards ne suffiront pas
s'ils ne sont pas accompagnés d'une
augmentation substantielle du budget
annuel de la défense
or celui-ci a été
a été gelé il restera stable jusqu'en
2025 je crois et du coup notamment par
rapport vous savez aux objectifs à
signer par l'OTAN à savoir que chaque
pays membre doit dépenser consacrer 2%
de son PIB aux dépenses militaire en
fait
la courbe elle monte c'est à dire que
l'Allemagne devrait atteindre les 2%
d'ici 2 ou 3 ans je crois mais ensuite
si le budget augmente pas
elle va elle va elle va redescendre donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose de long
terme et la deuxième chose que que
disent les spécialistes c'est que cette
cette transformation cette évolution ne
sera pas complète si elle ne
s'accompagne pas un d'une réorganisation
de l'armée or la Bundes vertes créée en
1955 10 ans après la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale sous l'égide en gros des
américains est une armée qui a été
organisée de telle façon qu'elle était
quasiment une opérationnelle pour se
battre parce que tout le monde voulait
bien une armée pour protéger contre les
Soviétiques mais le militarisme allemand
disant après la chute du nazisme
personne n'en voulait donc c'est une
armée qui est très lourde très
bureaucratique et peut adapter à au
combat étudiant nos combats jamais
puisque quand les Allemands sont sur des
terrains d'opération extérieurs ils font
de la logistique de la reconnaissance
mais il ne combattent pas
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut
que ça s'accompagne d'une révolution
aussi des mentalités alors celle-ci sans
doute que les Allemands sont moins
pacifistes et antimilitariste qu'ils ne
l'ont été et que beaucoup pensent qu'ils
le sont encore aujourd'hui mais il est
sûr que
ce pays
n'a pas n'a pas la culture
n'a pas de culture militaire n'a plus de
culture militaire pour des raisons pour
des raisons évidentes et ce qui pour
nous français semble assez évident l'Arc
de Triomphe le défilé du 14 juillet le
président de la République qui fait des
discours dans la cour des Invalides les
honneurs militaires et toutes ces choses
là
et s'auto présentant comme chef de
guerre et c'est inimaginable en
Allemagne
et ça je pense que ça va pas changer du
du jour au lendemain mais en tous les
cas il y a
un geste budgétaire et une prise de
conscience indéniable de la par des
élites politiques et sans doute des
élites éclairées du pays que
l'évolution du monde la guerre en
Ukraine les rapports qui se tendent
entre la Chine et les États-Unis font
que l'Allemagne ne peut plus se
contenter d'être une grande Suisse à
l'intérieur de l'Europe
bonjour général Peter de vaugler bonjour
vous êtes commandant de le record un
corps d'armée multinational c'est créé
en 1992 il y a maintenant 30 ans vous
avez d'ailleurs célébré les 30 ans de le
record cette année aujourd'hui il y a 6
nations cadres pardon qui font partie de
ce corps donc la France l'Allemagne
l'Espagne le Luxembourg mais aussi la
Belgique et la Pologne depuis cette
année on vous définit comme un corps de
réaction rapide européen c'est à dire
que si demain il y a une guerre entre
notamment l'UE ou le temps souhaite
intervenir dans une guerre c'est le
record qu'on enverra parmi les premiers
on est pas tout seul comme accord de
réaction rapide depuis la fin de la
guerre froide plusieurs corps de
réactions rapides sur le territoire
européen mais aussi en Amérique ont été
créés ou existé déjà ce sont des corps
nationaux donc ce sera un choix de nos
nations de nous envoyer de nous envoyer
au fond si si c'est leur volonté quand
on parle de le record on parle de
combien d'effectifs on est plus ou moins
1000 personnes ici au quartier général
du Corps européen un état-major de plus
ou moins 400 personnes et s'ils sont
personnes qui donnent les appuis
nécessaires pour le transport la mise en
place des tentes les communications et
les appuis de tous les jours quels sont
les principales compétences que doivent
avoir un corps de réaction rapide comme
le record commander et être capable de
se déployer rapidement en de façon
autonome dans la zone où on doit être
engagé je parlais des six nations cadres
juste avant comment ça se déroule le
commandement justement quand il y a six
pays qui décident comment ça se passe
sur le terrain dans le quartier général
du Corps européen les nations cadres
sont représentées au niveau des généraux
et il y a un système de rotation tous
les deux ans
belge je serai remplacé par un général
polonais à l'été prochain mais sur le
plan au-dessus du Corps européen il y a
un comité commun qui est composé de nos
chefs de la Défense et de représentants
des Affaires étrangères qui qui décident
du futur et des emplois du coréen c'est
quoi l'intérêt pour la France
l'Allemagne la Belgique et tous les pays
qui participent à le record d'avoir un
corps
multinational si je puis dire voilà
c'est surtout ça la multinationalité
comme vous voyez dans le monde autour de
nous la multinationalité joue un rôle
primordial les coalitions c'est avec des
collections qu'on gagne des guerres
qu'on peut s'imposer qu'on peut défendre
nos intérêts et ça nous donne une
certaine légitimité au Corps européen
comment est-ce que vous vous coordonnez
avec l'UE avec l'OTAN c'est parfois un
petit peu compliqué de s'y retrouver
pour les personnes qui s'y intéressent
comment ça comment ça se passe
dans le cadre de l'OTAN c'est assez
facile on fait partie de la Netto force
structure donc la structure des forces
de l'OTAN on a des réunions de
coordination de synchronisation
régulière et les spécialistes dans leurs
différents domaines ont des accès à aux
réseaux secrets de l'OTAN pour régler
les choses et coordonner les différentes
choses sur le plan de l'Europe on a des
contacts réguliers avec Bruxelles et
UMS de milieu européenne ainsi que les
MPC donc le triplane
aussi à Bruxelles c'est eux qui gèrent
un peu les l'emploi si jamais on est
employé comme
outil européen alors il y a les nations
cadres mais il y a aussi les nations
associées quelle est leur rôle et que
font-elle on était contents d'avoir des
nations associées à bord et la
particularité du nouveau de leur du
Corps européen c'est qu'on a des nations
associées autant mais on a su des
nations associées Union européenne et ça
souligne encore une fois ça met encore
une fois en avant la dualité du Corps
européen qui est un peu exceptionnel
quand on se compare avec les autres
corps donc ces nations là il nous
apporte du personnel et donc de
l'expertise de les expériences des
contacts dans leur capital qui nous aide
dans le travail de tous les jours alors
le siège de le record c'est à Strasbourg
pourquoi ce choix d'où est-ce que ça ça
vient il faut demander à nos
prédécesseurs bien sûr c'est une
décision qui a été pris par je pense
dans le temps de avec Monsieur Cole et
Monsieur Mitterrand au moment ils ont
créé le cœur européen le record je l'ai
dit en début de cette interview ça a été
créé en 1992 quels sont déjà les
opérations sur lesquelles le record a
participé
on a été employé comme j'ai déjà dit du
coton côté autant comme du côté européen
on a été au Kosovo on a été Afghanistan
on a fait des missions en Afrique pour
l'Union européenne on a été aussi sur
des rôles de d'alerte aussi bien pour
l'OTAN que pour l'Union européenne en
tant que fourchette contre pour le
groupe mais aussi les autres tâches que
le temps peut nous donner on a donc un
parcours assez riche en déploiement et
en utilisation la première mission de le
record dans le cadre de l'Union
européenne c'était au Mali qu'est-ce que
ça a changé par rapport aux missions
précédentes le fait que ce soit encadré
par l'Union européenne et que ce soit
une mission européenne mais je pense que
c'est justement ça auparavant c'était
une nation cadre qui reprenait les
commandes de mon de les tum et elle
mettait beaucoup de ces moyens mais ici
c'était un effort multinational et donc
à l'image de l'Europe et c'est pour ça
que ça a été d'un
accélérateur pour l'intégration
européenne que le européens a pris cette
fonction-là alors justement le record
c'est un peu considéré comme le début de
l'Europe de la défense il y a déjà
beaucoup de coopération est-ce que selon
vous c'est possible d'en avoir encore
davantage et d'intégrer demain de
nouveaux pays encore dans cette eurocort
et dans cette Europe de la défense qui
qui est en train de d'émerger on doit
être travaillé il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives qui peut encore avoir lieu
il y a des initiatives binationales
comme on voit avec différents pays comme
maintenant par exemple la France et la
Belgique dans le cadre de la capacité
motorisée mais il y a d'autres
initiatives multinationales bilatérale
Trilatérale qui peuvent encore améliorer
ce socle de la défense de l'Europe et
pour finir général dans les années qui
viennent d'ici 2024 le record sera
intégré à la joint force de l'Otan
qu'est-ce que ça ça signifie ça signifie
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
préparation vous voyez ici derrière nous
les tentes où on va dans quelques jours
commencer un grand exercice en interne
mais ce type d'exercice sera refait
semaine prochaine et on sera certifié
pendant toute une année sur différents
sujets par l'OTAN pour être certain
qu'on est prêt à assumer un rôle qui
serait de mener des opérations
360 degrés autour de l'OTAN pas
nécessairement un article 5 donc pas
vraiment un conflit de haute intensité
mais quand même un conflit qui peut
prendre une ampleur comme par exemple
l'opération barkham qui est bien connue
en France merci beaucoup général Peter
de vaugler merci d'avoir été avec nous
dans dans cette émission je rappelle que
vous êtes le commandant de le record
sur une Europe
nous sommes à l'escadron franco-allemand
c'est 130J à Évreux qui a été inauguré
en mars 2021 et je suis avec le
lieutenant-colonel Mike bonjour bonjour
alors quand vous êtes arrivé sur la base
comment ça s'est comment s'est passé
votre arrivée justement sur cette base
militaire et ma prêtre je suis arrivé
ici à la base 105 en avril 2021 et j'ai
commencé à travailler nous avons ouvert
l'élément de soutien national en avril
avec l'aide de la partie française et
nous avons continué à préparer l'arrivée
des soldats allemands ici à Évreux et
comment s'est passé l'adaptation avec
avec les militaires français sur sur la
base
ce n'était pas du tout un problème car
ici à Évreux nous avons reçu un soutien
incroyable du camp mais aussi de la
ville on était en toute tranquillité et
nous nous sommes sentis très à l'aise
dans la région dès le début nous avons
pu commencer notre travail avec beaucoup
de soutien et cela dès notre arrivée
est-ce que vos familles ont pu vous
suivre justement vous êtes parti pour
venir en France
des masters
la plupart des familles ne sont arrivées
que le 21 août nous parlons d'environ 20
familles qui sont arrivées ici à Évreux
c'est familles ont ensuite amené leurs
enfants à l'école et c'était bien sur un
défi pour elle mais surtout pour les
enfants qui devaient apprendre le
français on a eu des problèmes
relativement gérables c'était surtout
avec la barrière de la langue mais comme
je l'ai dit nous avons reçu du soutien
incroyable de la part de la base mais
aussi des écoles après la première année
nous pouvons maintenant dire que
l'intégration c'est extrêmement bien
déroulée nos enfants parlent de mieux en
mieux le français et les conversations
deviennent de plus en plus fluides et
quels sont les avantages d'un d'un
escadron franco-allemand quels sont les
objectifs
les objectifs et les principes de cet
escadron sont basés sur l'amitié et sur
la coopération et son avantage est bien
évidemment le fait qu'il soit binational
ici nous avons 10 avions c'est une
petite flotte donc mais nous opérons
ensemble car nous avons différents
niveaux d'expérience le but est
d'apporter aux autres d'apprendre les
uns des autres et bien évidemment de
faire preuve d'unité en matière de
sécurité et de défense entre la France
et l'Allemagne quelle a été votre
ressenti face à la création de de cet
escadron franco-allemand
j'ai découvert la création d'un relais
binational en 2016 et j'ai trouvé le
projet absolument intéressant j'avais
postulé à ce moment-là et je pense que
c'était la bonne décision à Évreux nous
essayons de mener à bien ce nouveau
projet et je vous assure qu'ici allemand
ou français nous sommes tous très très
engagés et ce qui est-ce qu'il existe
des différences selon vous entre la
formation militaire allemande et la
formation militaire française
dans une sécurité
différence car nous formons nos soldats
différemment dans beaucoup de choses en
Allemagne dès que les soldats arrivent
ici en France nous n'avons presque plus
de dossiers à gérer du fait de la
formation technique standardisée nous ne
cherchons plus les différences du moment
que nos soldats sont bien intégrés sur
le territoire français après que ce soit
entre soi en Allemagne on retrouve à peu
près les mêmes formations à la vie de
soldats est-ce que l'escadron est
représentatif de l'amitié
franco-allemande selon vous
l'histoire de nos deux pays est basée
sur de nombreux traités d'amitié comme
par exemple le traité de l'Elysée nos
pays ont de très nombreux contrats de
coopérations communes et ici vous pouvez
le voir ou le sentir cet escadron a
émergé de ces contrats d'amitié au cours
des dernières années et de mon point de
vue nous sommes des fort de l'amitié
franco-allemande et quel est votre votre
rôle au quotidien au sein de au sein de
l'escadron
de bataillon côté allemand et je suis
également le capitaine adjoint de
l'escadron le capitaine de l'escadron
est toujours fourni par la partie
française et ensemble nous sommes
l'équipe des capitaines d'escadron qu'on
peut également appeler les représentants
nationaux nous prenons toutes les
décisions ensemble et en même temps nous
devons également respecter les
réglementations nationales françaises en
particulier dans le domaine de la
discipline
merci beaucoup lieutenant colonel maïg
d'avoir répondu à nos questions donc je
rappelle que vous faites partie de
l'escadron franco-allemand ici à la base
aérienne 105 d'Évreux
zone Europe
en mars 2022 les nouveaux bâtiments de
l'escadron de transport binational c'est
130J ont été inaugurés à Évreux
l'occasion pour l'escadron
franco-allemande de prendre possession
de ses nouveaux locaux et pour en parler
avec nous je suis avec le commandant
romain vous faites partie justement de
l'escadron franco-allemand bonjour
bonjour à vous alors en mars 2020
l'inauguration a permis de mettre un
point final au projet de mise en place
d'une unité militaire mixte composée de
militaires français et allemands quel
était quelle est l'histoire de cette de
cette escadron pourquoi il a été mis en
place alors cet escadron fait suite à
une volonté politique donc un accord
entre l'Allemagne et la France d'une
coopération dans le domaine ministère et
plus spécifiquement dans le domaine du
transport aérien
et cette mise en place a conduit à des
aménagements des infrastructures mais il
a également fallu s'adapter à la
communication entre les militaires
français et les militaires allemands
alors comment s'est passé cette
adaptation et ce qu'on parle à la fois
français à la fois allemande ou est-ce
qu'on va plus parler anglais bien
écoutez dans cet accord comme on l'a
évoqué il a été évoqué que la langue de
travail de l'escadron était l'anglais
donc bien sûr quand nous sommes en avec
des Français on parle français quand les
Allemands sont ensemble ils parlent
allemand mais au quotidien quand on
parle avec des Français et des Allemands
on parle anglais alors justement c'est
ce qui a eu des échanges en amont pour
pour se préparer à cette à cette
installation sur cette sur cette base
militaire oui et bien écoutez depuis que
la lettre d'intention entre la France et
l'Allemagne était signée pour faire
cette coopération il y a eu des accords
et des réunions de préparation pour voir
comment cette escadron allait
fonctionner en termes de mission et en
termes de travail quotidien alors Évreux
n'est pas la ville la plus connue de
France pourquoi avoir choisi de créer
une collaboration et de fonder une unité
militaire mixte sur la base aérienne 105
d'Évreux bien écoutez comme vous l'avez
évoqué il y avait déjà une base aérienne
sur Évreux et la base aérienne 105
d'Evreux et la base du transport à
militaire pour la partie médian donc il
était tout naturellement prévu enfin
Évreux a été choisi pour accueillir
cette unité de transport et est-ce que
la création de cette escadron a donc
incité les militaires et les pilotes à
des formations est-ce qu'il y a eu des
déformations quand par exemple les
militaires allemands sont venus sur la
base aérienne d'Évreux et bien écoutez
pour la partie pilote pour ceux qui
conduisent les avions ils ont effectué
une formation comme les Français aux
États-Unis pour se faire former sur
l'avion et comment vous est-ce que vous
avez accueilli cette cette nouvelle
justement ce ce nouvel escadron est-ce
que ça a été un moment de stress par
exemple avant la mise en place et avant
la la rencontre avec avec les militaires
allemands ben écoutez pas forcément de
stress mais curiosité parce que avec une
unité un peu spéciale parce que c'est la
seule de la sorte en Europe et c'est la
première fois qu'on a une coopération
aussi poussée entre deux pays dans le
domaine militaire on va parler un petit
peu justement de comment se compose un
escadron alors les citoyens un petit peu
comme comme moi ne savent pas comment ça
se passe dans une dans une base
militaire comment se compose votre
escadron mais écoutez l'escadron il est
intégré comme toutes les unités de la
base aérienne à la base aérienne au sein
de l'escadron vous avez une organisation
avec un chef
un Chef français et un chef allemand
ils vont comment dirais-je ils vont
diriger des équipes donc une partie
opérationnelle qui s'occupe de voler
donc de réaliser les missions et une
partie soutien qui va s'occuper de
réparer on va dire les avions et
qu'elles sont vos missions à vous
personnellement au quotidien alors au
quotidien on fait des missions de
transport de personnel des transports de
fret on s'entraîne on s'entraîne dans le
cadre des opérations donc pour pouvoir
être déployé en opération la France est
engagée dans les opérations en Afrique
et à travers le monde donc on s'entraîne
à réaliser ces missions et ce cette
collaboration main dans la main
franco-allemande donc a vu le jour en
mars 2022 c'est très récent est là pour
objectif de perdurer dans dans les
décennies par exemple
pour l'instant oui évidemment vu les
infrastructures et les moyens qui sont
donnés c'est une coopération sur le sur
le long terme pour pouvoir s'entraîner
et peut-être un jour faire des
opérations ensemble merci beaucoup je
rappelle que vous êtes le commandant
romain d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et vous faites partie donc de l'escadron
franco-allemand ici à la base aérienne
d'Évreux zone Europe c'est terminé vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission un
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site
Internet et sur notre application radio
sensation et aussi sur TV 78 très bonne
soirée à tous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]